in the 1990s hong kong was a gateway for
asia to the world
then britain gave it back to china with
the agreement that china's leaders would
respect hong kong's free and open
society for at least the next 50 years
[Applause]
but just 25 years on
hong kong is now a police state with
thousands arrested jailed or forced to
flee
so what happened
i'm sulein wong china correspondent for
the economist i've spoken to a number of
those exiled to find out how china
managed to crush hong kong
[Music]
in 1989 chinese troops opened fire on a
crowd of demonstrators near tiananmen
square killing hundreds if not thousands
every year since then hong kongers have
gathered on june 4th in victoria park to
remember the massacre
but for the past two years the park has
stood empty
instead the protests have spread to
other cities such as here in london
hong kong used to be the only place on
chinese soil where you could commemorate
the victims of
the tiananmen square massacre but over
the past few years as the political
situation has become worse and more and
more people have been arrested the
authorities have also banned any
commemoration
the ruling communist party of china use
the military to indiscriminately murder
innocent people in the capital city of
beijing with life ammunition
one of the attendees in london is dr
chong kim wa an academic and a pollster
among hong kongers he's a bit of a
celebrity
but just a couple of months ago he made
the difficult decision to flee hong kong
for his own safety
today dr chung is on the move once more
i come to uk in rush so i stay with my
friend for six weeks and now i find my
own place
of course i'm not that willing to move
away from my hometown the place where i
grew up i always think that that is my
motherland and i have to stay there and
try to improve the situation
he hopes one day he'll return
but as china's grip on hong kong gets
ever tighter that hope grows dimmer by
the day
after all china's ambition to take full
control of hong kong goes back many
years
from the moment the trading port was
ceded to the british in 1842
the expectation was that hong kong would
one day be a part of china once more
renowned journalists ching chong grew up
in hong kong in the 1950s and 60s we all
consider ourselves as chinese because at
that time hong kong too many of us seems
to be a place
not belonging to us
eventually we'll return to china but in
the 1950s
china was weak
its leader mao zedong had unleashed
violent and destructive policies that
killed millions and left the country in
tatters we
came to the understanding that
the mainland china has a completely
different system and quite repressive as
well because we have seen all the
atrocities of the cultural revolution
at that time the mass killing in china
sent many dead bodies flowing from the
rivers in guangdong to hong kong
from that time onward nobody is thinking
of returning to china one day
but ching chong was still curious to see
china up close
so in the 1970s he became a journalist
for a pro-beijing newspaper when i went
to china poverty is still very rampant
everybody has to possess coupons in
order to be able to buy food
[Music]
meanwhile in hong kong rapid
industrialization and free trade meant
that business was booming
in 1997 the tiny territory's gdp was
one-fifth of china's
china needed the business connections
and financial expertise that hong kong
brought
or at least
it did then
i remember
as early as 1983
i told my wife
who was with me in beijing quietly that
unless china
scrapped its current political system
when china
get rich one day it will
pose a threat
to the world
and in the 1990s
and 2000s china did indeed get richer
the ruling communist party cultivated
china's global image opening up trade
routes and foreign investment
its gdp grew rapidly by the mid-2000s
the economic power balance had been well
and truly reversed
and then in 2012 xi jinping effectively
became the leader of china and increased
the party's grip on power
he introduced a law in the mainland
which clamped down on any form of
descent
and then set his sights on hong kong
to see it was no longer a city of growth
but a threat to his dominance
over the next few years the screws
tightened on hong kong
in 2019 hong kong's beijing back chief
executive carrie lam introduced a bill
which would have allowed criminal
suspects in hong kong to be tried on the
mainland this is a very important piece
of legislation that will help to uphold
justice
hong kongers like anna kwok
were horrified i was definitely very
angry
like how dare you do something like that
before 2047
when
we were supposed to still have our
autonomy i was quite worried that people
were not going to respond
to my surprise actually eventually
people came out to the streets and on
june 9th there was a million people
marching on the street
but always in the back of my mind i was
always so concerned that how long is
this gonna last um
and if the government decides to use
violence or if the government decides to
push hard on us to silence us are people
going to fight back
the people did fight back
but the huge demonstrations didn't
derail the communist party's crackdown
in 2020 it imposed a national security
law which effectively ended hong kong's
autonomy
this time resistance was minimal
huge sections of hong kong society from
business leaders to civil servants were
silent
why because the party had been preparing
for this day for a very long time
in the 1980s and 90s the communist party
started laying the foundations for
taking full control of hong kong
according to one estimate more than 80
000 officials from the mainland entered
hong kong using fake identities the aim
was for them to infiltrate every sector
of society by placing them in key civil
service roles
and creating underground party cells
the communist party even tried to
recruit ching chong
twice i was offered party membership and
twice i declined
the party used a shadowy department
known as the united front to try to
cultivate individuals and organizations
hong kongers were offered money power
and women in return for cooperation
one of the united front's main targets
was business
a politically powerful constituency in
hong kong
businessmen might be granted special
favors across the border in return for
their loyalty
well business they want a bigger slice
of the market and china pulls a very big
market to them
naturally they would be
happy to cooperate with them
it wasn't just businesses
decades of infiltration meant the police
customs and immigration were also in the
pocket of the party
so when the security law came in
the loyalty of hong kong's security
forces was never in doubt
it also tried to cultivate relationships
with those who made up hong kong's
vibrant civil society
journalists teachers lawyers and
academics like dr chung
for many decades he's been contacted by
so-called middlemen
so what is this what this is a guy
keep in touch with me for
at least
six years
and whenever he come to hong kong he
would come to hong kong for you to see
me
and had a dinner or a lunch to talk on
different yeezus
he looks very friendly
happy chinese new year happy mid autumn
yeah i always like that always like that
dr chung's experience isn't unusual many
of the hong kongers i spoke to said
they'd been contacted by middlemen
for decades the middlemen were courteous
and friendly even
but once china imposed the national
security law in hong kong the middlemen
became a lot more intimidating
someone
who was close to the
pro-establishment he told me that you
are regarded as someone who is not
obedient enough
so you will be in trouble of course i i
took that as a signal and later
he
sent me another message ask me would you
consider
leaving hong kong for a while to take a
rest
over the past two years dr chung was
approached by the police several times
but he was reluctant to leave his
homeland
one of my best friends and my colleague
he was sentenced
to prison for three weeks
he was always
gentle
moderate
of course firm
and
he was sent into prison
it was a very
important one warning signal and i
realized that going to prison is
not as simple as we imagine
my parents
are quite aged
i imagine a situation
is it
tolerable for myself
to see my age-old parents come to stand
in person's receiving
and
i would say that
that imagination is quite saddening
he fled
now in britain dr chung continues to be
outspoken
with his friend a radio producer they
host a weekly podcast discussing what's
going on in hong kong
when i make a decision to move to uk
i always say that i refuse to sweep up
my mind
and keep writing and keep
talking
even though he's no longer in hong kong
the middlemen continue to contact him
anna kwop is exiled in washington dc
she doesn't know if she'll ever be able
to return to hong kong
part of me thinks that even if i go back
to hong kong even if i get jailed for
let's say five years or ten years i
thought it could be worth it just
because that is where i grew up and that
is my home right but then
you know it was a very hard struggle
because
you have to decide if you do want to go
back that means that you kind of have to
silence yourself she now works for an
advocacy group called the hong kong
democracy council we try to guide the
policy discussion so that we can drive
future developments that can discourage
the chinese communist party from further
eroding our freedoms
the world should realize first that
even though things may seem to be
happening just locally in hong kong
actually they're also trying to use
their economic influence as a leverage
to control what people in the free world
can say or cannot say
[Music]
three years on from the hong kong
protests thousands of hong kongers have
gathered in parliament square in london
our true identity is always a hong
konger
many hong kongers i've spoken to say
that hong kong isn't just an isolated
incident and in fact there are many
lessons for the rest of the world from
what has happened to hong kong from the
way the chinese communist party has
crushed liberalism in the city over the
past three years
please don't take freedom and democracy
for granted
all the strategies china used to convert
hong kong to convert hong kong from
free society into our authoritarian one
are in operation in your society
so
caring for hong kong is no longer for
hong kong's sake but for your own sake
to read more about how china crushed
hong kong click on the link don't forget
to subscribe and thank you for watching